I've never gone by the studio in $7.99  seventh Avenue he was in the studio with  Paul silver mom I said Paul I think you  should show up for this Oscar event  because you guys have a good shot at it  you know you could you could possibly  get nominated and possibly win and you  know Paul we look great for this [ __ ] no  question you're not gonna talk to me and  I've got nothing but I won't care about  don't go and he didn't go that's the  first year I I had I come back to the  orchestra my baton down and go up and  make a speech and pick up the Oscar for  Lennon and McCartney on let it be this  is fantastic  I just wanted an excuse to get close to  it and I wish that the Beatles were all  here together tonight to receive this  but I have to get back to Kentucky  Orchestra on their behalf thank you very  much there was still love for bothered  alone